here with us is house minority leader
kevin mccarthy to discuss
ari good evening congressman this this
is absolutely insane
what can republicans do to stop these
dangerous cuts from going into effect
you're right it's insane and president
trump was correct he had secured the
border
and while he was down at the border
making the case of what
president biden has done with his
executive orders making it more unsafe
than we've ever seen in more than two
decades
the democrats were in committee slashing
funding
for immigration protection by more than
a billion dollars
that further customs and border
protections for ice
and then removing two billion dollars
from finishing building the wall
we have watched fentanyl increase by
more than 300 percent
that goes to every city in america it's
going to kill the individuals there
but now we're watching people coming
across this border will be more than a
million people
who cross this border illegally will go
across
our nation not tested for covet or
others right but this
is what has happened and with all this
run along the border
you know what else the democrats did
they didn't add one extra dollar to the
border patrol agents
who are working overtime who are being
pushed like they've never been pushed
before
to protect us it's not just enough for
the democrats to defund
our cities now they are defunding the
borders
making this nation unsafe in so many
places
and speaking of defunding congressman
democrats are trying to claim the gop
is responsible for defunding the police
but jenn saki had trouble
proving it today listen
of republican members of congress saying
they want to defund the police
i think most people would argue that
actions are more important than words
wouldn't you say
congressman they're really going to keep
pushing this narrative
aren't they the republicans are
defunding police
it's just the biggest lie ever 73 people
were shot in chicago this weekend
a man and woman were pulled from their
car in chicago
and killed on the streets last week we
all watched the show of the two young
children
working walking in their neighborhoods
in new york being trampled by the person
running
and being shot at this is what has
happened when the democrats across this
nation
defunded the police but what's worse is
they're doing it now to our borders as
well
it is go it is going across this nation
and now they lie to the world
this is the same white house that said
there was no crisis at the border either
well look at what kamala did i mean she
went to a place where there was no
problem
but i want to turn to the origins of
covet now which which your republican
colleagues are
pursuing yet democrats are ignoring so
nbc uh nightly news dropped this
bombshell about
the head of the wuhan lab at the center
of the lab leak
theory dr she herself
has multiple connections with military
officials
she and others collaborated with a
military scientist on coronavirus
research
and with another military scientist joe
yusen in december 2019
in fall 2020 an article that scientist
authored
lists him in a footnote as deceased nbc
has been unable to ascertain
the circumstances of his death
congressman how can democrats continue
to ignore evidence like this
i have no idea i don't know what the
communist chinese party has on the
democrats
but it must be powerful republicans just
rolled out eight pillars to hold china
accountable
the first thing that needs to happen is
declassify the information so all the
world can know
in the gain of function research that
has been funding
inside china make sure nih does not fund
china russia north korea or iran as well
let's make let's allow americans those
600
000 americans their families who have
lost their lives let them
sue china to hold them accountable and
why would we ever allow
china to have the next winter olympics
why would the world reward them
let's move the olympics as well well
there's a lot to do
congressman thanks so much thank you
judge hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else